là où j'avais on nous amène à chacun des
petits cadeaux et louis vuitton la bonne
habitude d'arriver les mains et venues
dans non non non c'est non voyez vous on
vous les aides n'ont rien vu d'autre ou
alors la syrie soucier des chaussures à
mon gamin qui vous dit même si rigole
mais là je n'y allais d'alès et 42 ans
j'ai été comme hiver bien c'est fou rire
l'intérieur suite ça c'est pour un la
terrine ses terrines du berry sévère et
goûter sap il paraît que vous êtes bien
copine avec julie gayet winfrey goûté ça
n'y changera de son flamby pour mathieu
j'hésitais parce que j'ai entendu parler
qu'il avait des nuits un peu folle et
bagis a mené une petite blouse à moi je
voulais y sommes une vieille et pierre
toulouse où ça peut des fois réveiller
votre libido fromage fabriqué pour le
dvd pour ma petite l'éliminer c'est
l'amour est plus fort mais c'est nous à
fromage qui pue pas c'est comme un
bonhomme qui transpire moyenne arnaque
j'ai pour ma copine d'école j'ai mis
longtemps à se paie que c'est en ce lieu
c'est de notre vie de prune de cet
officier est plein de vitamines qui
goûtait tout faire monter au plafond
théorique saab la côte d'ivoire le
boulot c'est très bon c'est un peu fort
c'est là bien que je fais trop gentillet
tous les sens la vue à la retraite dans
ce pays bien dans son rapport annuel
dont la guerre voilà ça dépend ce que
l'on reparlé avec des maximas aussi pour
maxime nous a dit que c'était le petit
dernier la morale dernier c'est le
premier de la classe mais c'est le
dernier arrivé on l'a donc vous l avoue
prendre des forces
très bien donc on est le premier de la
clotte faut pas décevoir la maîtresse
alors ça c'est mes coups de coeur de la
soirée ou quoi c'est quoi ce savent pas
exactement par quel bout de prendre que
mont joli et jean-michel donc chamia
murviel lingerie à moi à l'époque où
j'avais une poitrine grue comme la dune
du pilat
tu veux te je l'allaité jusqu'à neuf ans
que c'est ça qui m'a foutu les nichons
comme des ben c'est pas bien tu vas tu
vas t'amuser avec sa magie oui d'après
ce que j'ai compris il en a je succès
qui gratouille lebron23 on va voir ça
arrange ensemble mon petit mignon je
suis là faites vous pour venir visiter
mais comme étaient arrivés hier et puis
tu as besoin de remontants oui c'est
vrai mais je dis il faut qu'on y donne
le gros lot alors je t'offre monfils
aura coûté à christian cataldo trop tout
pouvoir vient bien façon alors irrité
alors il a jamais fait mal à personne
j'ai la garantie qui te fera je te
garantis pour qui te fera du bien alors
pour benjamin bonne idée à qui on n'a vu
l'autre jour que comment dont notre
président est en macro a offert un
chevalet au président chinois hu est
donc toi on a ramené à poney hillairaud
boy t'attend de passe
voilà